the first one will deal with that I in
water difference the first one idiot I
think is what we called midpoints this
one this ringing a bell so this is like
you've got two points right what's the
one point that is exactly halfway
between yours so I'm going to give you
the formula and then we're going to have
a go and see how it works over here so
the midpoint which is usually indicated
with um a capital M like that here's the
formula which is looks like this
yes still edit rate it on the video
Capital m is midnight so here's the
midpoint formula and you can see because
what you're going to get out of this is
a point it's formatted like a point
you've got your blankets around the
edges you've got a comma in the middle
there's an x-coordinate and a
y-coordinate so each one you're adding
them and then you're dividing by 2
all you're doing is you're working at
the average that's what you do so for
example let's do the midpoint of these
two guys over here so I'll write that as
midpoint and because between a and B
I'll write a V gently and then I'm going
to look and I'm going to say ok which
would be my x-coordinate which was a
wire yeah if you've got another color
there share a favor and I'm going to
orange it's got another color there this
is really useful I am actually going to
label onto my coordinate which ones are
the X's on which ones are the Y's to
have a look you 2 comma 3 which on this
and which was related to the X is the 2
and the 3 is the Y is alphabetical
journey for that so I'm going to write
this as x1 y1 you don't have to do this
but I highly encourage you do because
then you can have it in side view
oh this is which one which number fits
where and then trying to keep all your
hair
Master so you've got one point and it's
X&Y and then you've got the other point
and it also has an x and y x - 1 - yeah
does that effect right let's crunch and
see what happened so we'll do the
exercise X 1 plus X 2 is 2 and there's
negative 3 so both negative and then I
divided by 2
there's the X's what am I going to put
in for the white 2 / 5 / - okay I'm just
going to quickly calculate this I could
go to my calculator but these are pretty
simple numbers that we're starting so 2
plus negative 3 is 2 - 3
yes which is negative 1 1 this is just
negative 1 over 2 what about on the
right hand side what am I getting here 4
over 2 which is 2 okay now you can see I
think actually find where this is on my
original eirick let's go and have a look
negatives are hollow t is 0 and here's
negative 1 do you agree
so negative pop is halfway between here
and here and where - it's going to be
there then you're right yeah does it
look like this one yeah okay